trump clearly lost he's going to be
moving on
my point is this we would have been at
30 000. trump would have been here
um we wouldn't have had this stimulus
package in your opinion if trump was
still president
2021 where would have that have gone
because those issues would
are still going to be there china
everything i don't agree
i don't disagree i i absolutely don't
disagree but i think what would have
happened is the following
i think the moment trump gets re-elected
china would have sat there saying we
have to now negotiate with this guy
because we cannot handle four more years
we got to go figure out a way to sit
down with this guy and get these tariffs
on their order what does he want
let's negotiate with them number two i
think if another four more years
iran's economy couldn't handle it
there's no way in the world iran's
economy can handle four more years of
what they've gone through they would
have to come up and say
let's do something what the iran's
economy did is saying just hang tight
till the next election this guy's going
to be out
we'll be able to get what we want from
u.s and it's going to be buying
hopefully if it's buying we'll get that
150 billion everything's going to work
itself out
just be patient right so those two would
have to negotiate with trump that they
don't have to there is no urgency
anymore
remember reagan gets elected what's the
first thing iran does
releases who the hostages the hostages
the day the moment he gets elected and
who does reagan give credit to
carter you gave credit to carter did you
i never gave credit to carter but reagan
gave credit to carter meaning reagan's
trying to be
the guy that's passing the tour he
doesn't want to say hey i'm the guy that
scared me of course they were scared
reagan was going to do something and
reagan said i'm going to attack you but
he says listen i'm going to give it to
carter it's all good
he did the right way he won carter's
people over got 49 out of 50 states
i think right now the leverage the
urgency of trump was elected a lot of
those guys are going to say oh my gosh
if this guy's going to be here dude we
got to figure out a way to get along
with him send somebody to go meet with
them
send somebody go meet with pompeo send
somebody go meet with uh pence
we have to do it urgency officially went
down to zero there is zero
urgency today for those guys to have to
do a deal today
and by the way here's the other part
every time trump said
powell you got to keep the interest
rates lower you got to keep the interest
rates lower
i've never been a fan of that i've never
been a fan of that
when it comes down to taxes here's my
philosophy with taxes what do we owe
well do you want to delay this for next
year you want to pay it off this year
what's it looking like like this i'm
gonna have to eventually pay this four
hundred thousand dollars yes paid
anyways paid right now paid writing a
paid right now let's get
knocked out of the way i don't want to
delay
headaches of future i want to get it
knocked out of the way today it's just
my philosophy what i do when i go
through taxes now china iran all these
other guys are saying
we're fine guys don't worry about it
these next guys are going to work with
us they're not like trump
they're going to work with us we're
going to get exactly what we want and
they are china is going to get exactly
what they want
so temporarily market may do well
long term china got stronger the next
four years
iran got to get stronger the next four
years russia got stronger the next four
years
temporarily they took a hit but you're
officially seeing china is going to come
make a comeback
of being the talk of town and do you
really think they're going to take him
to the tribunal and hold china
accountable for what they do with the
coronavirus and releasing it to the
world
what do you think is the percentage of
u.s led by a biden to go whole china
accountable
what do you think it is well if if he
includes allies and uses multilateralism
like
uh general mattis said to use rather
than america first
yeah i would hope that the world would
do this
with allies together rather than trying
to do it alone do you actually think
biden's going to go out there and
encourage other nations to go up and
hold china accountability
let's say i'm asking let's see do you
think he's going to do it are you
leaning towards yes or no i mean
obviously i don't think
biden is a tough guy and i don't think
he's going to like
hold you know but let's give the guy a
shot let's see what he does
but do i yes or no will you think i
think he will yes
i'm not sure i don't okay that's a
fairness my gut is insane
he's gonna go get him or he's not gonna
do it i would hope he does and i hope
the world would join up as allies